- La ville de O'Fallon,
au Missouri, est située à
à peine 45 minutes
du centre-ville de Saint-Louis.
Ici, on entre dans le comté
rural de Saint-Charles,
dans un terreau républicain.
Nick Schroer a été élu
représentant de district à
la Chambre du Missouri en 2016.
Aujourd'hui, il tente d'accéder
au Sénat. Et pour l'instant,
sa campagne se passe plutôt
bien; il multiplie les
rassemblements militants.
"Les républicains à qui je parle
sont fous de joie lorsqu'ils
apprennent que c'est moi qui a
parrainé la loi anti-avortement.
Ils me demandent
des autographes, et demandent
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
pour m'aider."
Il y a ceux qui l'admirent
et ceux qui le détestent.
À l'extérieur de la salle
où se tient le rassemblement
républicain, une centaine
de militants pro-choix ont fait
la route depuis Saint-Louis
pour perturber la rencontre.
La stratégie a fonctionné.
Le jeune avocat avoue que bien
de ses supporters ont décidé
de rebrousser chemin.
(slogans sésésés)
Mais les manifestations contre
sa loi ne l'arrêtent pas.
"Je sais qu'il y a des
manifestations ce soir, je leur
dis bienvenue et je suis ouvert
au débat, en autant que ce soit
pacifique."
Mais le débat sur l'avortement
semble déjà clos et sans appel.
Il parle plutôt d'éduquer
ses adversaires. Il croit
profondément que cette loi est
la volonté de ses électeurs,
et de Dieu.
Il veut donc aller plus ...
Après l'avortement chirurgical,
il veut s'attaquer à la pilule
abortive dès l'automne.
Son objectif est d'interdire
ces pilules au Missouri,
et même d'empêcher leur envoi
par la poste.
- Parce qu'il y a des choses
dont on pensait qu'on était
à l'abri, et en fait,
on n'est pas à l'abri.
- Yara Holt n'est pas éteee
des nouvelles prises de position
de Nick Schroer.
- Là, c'est juste le premier
domino. Et en fait, on s'attend
tous à ce qu'iaiaiait beaucoup
de choses qui arrivent,
et qui continuent dans la même
direction. En fait, ils vont
peut-être grappiller des choses
à gauche ààà droite.
- En tant que femme, elle dit
ne plus reconnaître le Missouri
où elle avait décidé de
s'établir il y a 15 ans.
- t t t pas seulement
la question de l'avortement
ou des choses comme ça, c'est
un exemple, dans un mouvement
général où on se sent pas aussis
traitées comme les autres,
où on a peur. C'est la peur.
Bon, maintenant, c'est ça,
et demain, ça va être quoi?
- Elle et son conjoint songent
maintenant sérieusement
à quitter le Missouri.
- Il va falloir qu'on pense
à notre futur aussi, nous,
en tant que citoyens. Je veux
dire, je peux pas rester ici,
dans un endroit où on me
considère... moins que quelqu'un
d'autre. Donc...
Et nous, on a dechchchance,
parce que, en fin, nous avons
tous les deux la double
nationalité, donc la France
nous accueillera, je pense,
les bras otststs.
- Nick Schroer, lui, voit plus
que jamais son avenir dans
un État de plus en plus
à son image. Et il n'est pas
prêt d'arrêter sa croisade.
Il prie pour que sa loi
soit adoptée par tous
les États américains.
"Nous avons besoin que tous
les États reconnaissent
le caract s s sacré de la vie
et qu'ils bannissent
l'avortement", dit-il.
Gonflé à bloc par l'abandon
de l'arrêt Roe contre Wade
et porté par ses convictions,
il se dit prêt pour
de nouvelles batailles.
Peu importe les divisions
qu'elles provoquent, et même si,
de toute évidence, elles rendent
la vie de moins en moins
paisible au Miss...
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, O'Fallon.